bonjour victor bonjour charles ça fait
plus voir et bon jeu
avec plaisir de te revoir parce que
pour ceux qui auraient eu l'occasion de
voir la vidéo qu'on a fait en commun sur
ta chaîne vidéo qui portait sur la
rivalité entre philosophie et et
rhétorique est ce que tu pourrais victor
te présenter pour ceux qui ne te
connaîtraient pas et nous dire pourquoi
nous sommes ici aujourd'hui
ouais donc je suis quelqu'un qui a eu
d'abord une première carrière comme
chercheur donc j'ai fait une thèse en
rhétorique est le sujet qui
m'intéressait c'était de redécouvrir les
exercices qu'utilisaient les citoyens
dans la grèce et la rome antique pour se
former à la prise de parole en public et
donc il ya certains de ces exercices qui
sont un peu évident donc par exemple on
sait que pratiquer une controverse est
quelque chose qui nous permet
d'apprendre à produire des arguments et
d'apprendre anticipé des objections mais
il y avait des exercices dont la
finalité était plus obscures par exemple
la prosopopée la prosopopée c'est un
discours du type que dirait la ville
d'athènes si elle était assiégée donc
c'est un disco on doit apprendre à
produire une parole depuis un autre
point de vue que le nôtre et donc moi ce
qui m'intéressait c'était de me demander
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on a créé ça
quelle est la finalité de ces exercices
en quoi ça fait de nous de meilleurs
citoyens avec cette dimension éthique ou
des citoyens plus efficace avec cette
dimension pragmatique et donc j'ai
travaillé à faire ça
j'ai travaillé à dépoussiérer les
exercice de rhétorique antique et sur
cette base j'ai répondu à des appels
d'offres pour pouvoir donner des
formations dans les écoles niveau
collège et lycée et je suis allé
partager c'est bas ces outils sur le
terrain avec cette idée que finalement
beaucoup de ces exercices permettait de
travailler sur l'empathie parce qu'on
peut créer des situations du type je
sais pas moi que dirait une petite fille
quand elle rentre chez elle après avoir
été harcelés donc on peut jouer sur ces
choses ou alors que dirait le professeur
quand il doit sanctionner un élève alors
que là
la décision est difficile à prendre donc
il y avait tout un tas de choses comme
ça qu'on pouvait qu'on pouvait
expérimenté non seulement pour faire des
élèves
des citoyens plus apte à porter des
causes qui leur tiennent à coeur mais
aussi des citoyens plus sensibles aux
liens qui les lient aux autres élèves de
la classe mais aussi aux professeurs et
donc non je vis de ce que je suis
capable de créer à savoir délivre des
formations et des vidéos sur youtube
donc j'ai essayé de créer un système qui
permettait d'avoir une vie proche de
cette vie qui me fait toujours rêver que
celle de quelqu'un qui consacre sa vie à
la création d'idées sauf que je me
finance pas par de l'argent public je me
finance par l'argent que je capable de
gagner très bien alors à cette occasion
donc je rappelle que tu as une chaîne
youtube victor ferry way dans laquelle
tu propose des vidéos des analyses on
pourrait dire d'études de cas en quelque
sorte de rhétorique ses traits c'est
très ludique je dirais dans la forme
tout en étant exigeant sur le fond tu as
une chaîne secondaire je tiens à en
parler parce que taschen secondaire
s'appelle l'atelier de rhétorique et tu
propose des exercices pratiques à des
spectateurs et athée abonnés et tu as
également publié un livre dont on
parlera tout à l'heure mais je le montre
dès à présent donc douze leçons de
rhétorique pour prendre le pouvoir et je
te poser la question de pourquoi prendre
le pouvoir mais ça ce sera pour pour
tout à l'heure alors victor tu as
commencé déjà à nous parler un petit peu
de de ce que tu faisais est ce que tu
pourrais nous dire ce qu'est la
rhétorique premièrement et à quoi ça
sert ouais donc en fait les
les deux définitions de la rhétorique
qui sont peut-être les plus les plus
connus il ya celles qu'on trouve chez
aristote et donc aristote il a une bonne
vision de la rhétorique comme un outil
qui permet de persuader donc il dit
précisément la science de l'art
d'observer ce qui dans chaque situation
est propre à persuader donc il a
vraiment eu la preuve d'un artisan qui
travaille sur ce domaine et qui se
demandent comment est-ce qu'on peut le
faire plus efficacement il n'y a pas
tellement de dimension éthique dans son
approche de la danse on approche de la
rhétorique il ya également chez chez
cicéron jc cicéron il a une discussion
une définition qui était encore plus
large qui est la rhétorique finalement
c'est un art de bien parler et c'est
très bien en fait c'est très vrai mais
moi ce que je trouvais important c'était
d'ajouter une finalité à 7
à cet art de la rhétorique et donc moi
aujourd'hui je définirais la rhétorique
comme un outil qui permet de changer nos
convictions qu'il y a un problème en des
mouvements qui permettent de les régler
il ya cette dimension politique
évidemment chez chez aristote mais dans
sa définition elle ressort pas alors que
pour moi c'est très important qui est
cette idée que on ne prend pas la parole
pour faire le malin on ne prend pas la
parole pour que ce soit joli on prend la
parole pour que ça puisse motiver notre
public à l'action j'ajoute à ma
définition une dimension éthique qui est
que je pense qu'il faut dans nos
discours s'assurer que l'on en appel à
ce qu'il ya de meilleur chez nos
interlocuteurs donc ça c'est quelque
chose que j'ai c'est quelque chose
auquel je tiens parce que c'est facile
en fait de créer un mouvement autour de
passions tristes donc un mouvement du
type regardez votre bond sera tellement
votre monde et votre vie sera tellement
meilleur une fois qu'on aura supprimé
tous ces méchants qui vous empêche
d'être heureux aujourd'hui on peut très
bien créer un mouvement autour de ça
mais ce dans quoi ça puise basse et des
choses comme la haine et le ressentiment
et je pense que les mouvements qui
naissent de ça ils peuvent avoir une
efficacité très puissante à court terme
mais à la fin c'est pas c'est pas bien
pour le bien commun et donc c'est pour
ça que je considère qu'un bon orateur
c'est quelqu'un qui évidemment va
commencer en parlant des problèmes parce
que c'est c'est ça notre rôle en tant
qu'orateur c'est de prendre la parole
parce qu'il ya des problèmes et qu'on
veut les régler mais à la fin du
discours l'émotion dans laquelle doit
être le public c'est quelque chose qui
est plus proche de la fierté de la
détermination donc c'est comme ça que
définirait la rhétorique aujourd'hui un
art de créer des mouvements à partir des
problèmes qu'on juge grave le tout en
visant ce qu'il ya de meilleur chez nos
interlocuteurs très bien alors ça va
pour le coup nous donner l'occasion de
rebondir sur de nombreuses choses parmi
tout ce que tu as dit c'est très
intéressant alors la première chose sur
laquelle j'aimerais bien qu'on vienne
c'est
cette spécificité de la rhétorique
qui est donc un instrument qui est un
outil
qui n'a pas en soi de connotation morale
j'avais prévu d'ailleurs une question je
peux te poser dès à présent la question
c'est est-ce que la rhétorique et morale
immoral ou amoral et si je dis ça on
peut l'illustrer assez facilement
aujourd'hui on va dire à mes la
rhétorique sait ce qu utilise par
exemple ceux qui font du marketing ou
ceux qui font de la publicité donc la
rhétorique c'est un instrument de
manipulation
et moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec
cette position parce que l'outil va
dépendre de la finalité qu'on lui donne
donc si on veut utiliser un outil pour
manipuler on peut le faire si on veut
utiliser un outil pour édifier ou pour
inspirer on peut le faire également moi
j'ai plutôt tendance à dire la publicité
utilise les techniques efficaces la
rhétorique est elle morale immoral loi
morale qu'est ce que tu en penses elle
est amoral la rhétorique est là comme
tout outil doit l'être la rhétorique est
amoral ce qu'il ya c'est que tous les
grands auteurs qui se seront penchés sur
la question à un moment donné ils
doivent se poser la question de l'impact
de leur enseignement et donc certains
vont certains vont développer une
approche plutôt cynique en se disant
l'enfer est pavé de mauvaises intentions
de toute façon qui sommes nous pour
savoir si nous faisons le bien et le mal
et c'est donc à des gens qui vont
assumer tout à fait ça en se disant bien
moi mon travail c'est de céder là les
gens à être être efficace et si j'arrive
à faire ça c'est déjà bien
moi j'ai développé une approche où je
considère que l'éthique est importante
mais les tickets les paliers à la
rhétorique neil est lié à moi voilà il
ya ce que j'ai envie de à ce que j'ai
envie d'en faire et à la manière dont
j'aimerais que mes que mes élèves
l'utilisent et quand je dis ça je ne
veux pas que mes élèves l'utilisent avec
mon éthique je veux qu'il utilise en se
posant des questions éthiques alors ça
c'est intéressant parce que ça remet
complètement en cause cette espèce de
séparation qu'on fait entre la
rhétorique et la philosophie qu'on a
abordé dans la vidéo qu'on a fait en
commun et ça remet même en cause de ce
que disait socrate lorsqu'il disait que
finalement
le sophiste était un manipulateur dans
le sens de quelqu'un qui va tordre la
vérité toi ce que tu dis c'est que
effectivement il ya un usage possible de
la rhétorique qui sera immorale qui sera
en opposition à la vérité mais il est
tout à fait possible de l'adapter à une
démarche vertueuse
je pense que socrate a raison quand il
quand on regarde les sophistes qu'il
avait sous les yeux quand on prend
quelqu'un comme gorge et à sang là quand
on regarde l'oeuvre de gorgias qu'est ce
qu'il a ce qu'est ce qu'on a sous la
main on a quelque chose comme un traité
du non-être qu'est ce que c'est ça c'est
quelqu'un qui s'est amusé à prendre une
thèse qui apparemment est indéfendable
rien n'existe et qui s'est amusé à la
défendre donc c'est à dire que c'est un
exercice intellectuel mais qui n'a mais
dont les conséquences pratiques sont
nuls
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autres chez gorgias
on a un éloge d'hélène donc un éloge
d'hélène qu'est ce que c'est donc hélène
qui est un personnage qui était
unanimement blâmer dans la mythologie
des citoyens auxquels il s'adressait
parce qu'on la considère responsable
comme la gréce ponsable de la guerre de
troie parce que c'était une courtisane
et c est donc lui va faire un discours
il va faire l'éloge des laines donc est
ce que c'est que ça c'est un discours où
ils vous disent regardez ces deux choses
que vous considérez comme absolument
indéfendable moi je vais la défendre il
s'est en grande partie comme ça qui
gagnait sa vie il gagnait sa vie en
étant capable de faire des discours où
les gens applaudissaient se disait mais
c'est un génie ce qui lui permettait
d'avoir des clients donc du point de vue
de socrate évidemment que c'est un
problème d'avoir des d'avoir des
personnes comme ça dans la d'avoir des
personnes comme ça dans la cité mais on
peut tout à fait avoir une autre
approche de la rhétorique moi ce que je
prends des sophistes c'est tout c'est
tous ces exercices qui permettent
effectivement d'être une bonne
gymnastique intellectuelle parce que
faire un éloge paradoxal faire l'éloge
de la guerre de la maladie d'une mouche
d'un moustique ou que sais-je bah ça
nous pousse effectivement dans nos
retranchements à aller contre nos idées
reçues à muscler notre capacité à voir
les choses de différents points de vue
mais une fois qu'on prend la parole en
public en tant qu'orateur ben là on a un
ethos et donc on peut plus se permettre
de défendre une chose et son contraire
et c'était ça que c'était ça que
dénoncer socrates c'était l'idée que
finalement bas il y avait des gens qui
parce qu'ils étaient à l'aise à l'oral
avait la capacité de défendre n'importe
quoi en fonction de là où est leur
intérêt et je pense que là la cohérence
est quelque chose de fondamental et
socrate est d'ailleurs un modèle à cet
égard il aurait pu s'amuser avec la
définition de la justice dira oui mais
votre justice n'est pas la vraie justice
et cetera donc je vais me sauver et
éviter mon jugement non socrates a dit
ben moi j'ai toujours vécu en accord
avec la justice donc que j'accepte votre
jugement donc il nous donne un modèle
2001 de concordance entre la parole et
les actes et ça c'est quelque chose que
je suis que je récupère en plus parce
que ça nous rend bien bien meilleure
dans les débats si on reprend un petit
peu à la base des choses je suis
quelqu'un qui voudrait apprendre à
s'exprimer correctement
publiquement et efficacement parce que
je me sens animé d'une cause que j'ai
envie de porter dans la société un an on
va là on schématise un petit peu le
profil type de celui qui pourrait
vouloir apprendre la rhétorique
qu'est-ce que tu conseillerais à 7
personnes qui voudraient se lancer dans
la rhétorique et qui n'auraient pas
encore le bagage et l'outillage pour
pouvoir s'exprimer publiquement
on travaille sur mon travail sur trois
choses on travaille d'abord sur sa
vision
et donc on peut le faire de façon de
façon très élaborée en suivant le schéma
d'un manifeste donc un blâme de ce qui
ne va pas dans le monde actuel une une
série de mesures et d'étapes
qui permettrait de changer ce statut quo
est une vision une utopie de ce vers
quoi le monde devrait aller ça c'est la
première chose c'est l'écriture d'un
manifeste et le manifeste il faut pas le
prendre comme un texte définitif qui va
qui va tout régler il faut le prendre
plus comme un comme un contrat
avec nous mêmes et revenir régulièrement
à ce manifeste en se disant est ce que
dans cette prise de parole est ce que
dans cette décision je suis en accord
avec cette vision que j'ai couché sur le
papier ça c'est la première chose
clarifier pourquoi est-ce qu'on veut
prendre la parole parce que ça permet
d'éviter cette tendance à se dire ouais
j'ai envie d'être plus respecté il ya
plein de gens qui viennent me voir avec
ça j'ai envie d'être meilleur dans les
débats j'ai envie d'être plus respecté
j'ai envie qu'on m'écoute et ça c'est
c'est pas là c'est pas dans cette
optique qu'il faut commencer la question
c'est qu'est ce que j'ai envie de porter
et le manifeste permet de faire ça une
fois qu'on a fait ça on va travailler
encore sur deux autres choses on va
travailler sur des exercices
des exercices par exemple le disent haut
et logo donc un exercice où on va
prendre une thèse on va aller aussi loin
dans la défense d'une position et
ensuite on va aller aussi loin dans la
défense de la position opposée donc ce
sont des exercices qui permettent de
développer le muscle de l'argumentation
on peut faire aussi des exercices qui
permet de travailler sur le style donc
par exemple on va prendre un classique
on va le lire jusqu'à ce que l'on soit
captivé par l'histoire ensuite on va
fermer le livre et on va essayer
d'écrire la fin du passage comme ça
après on peut comparer nos choix
stylistiques avec les choix de l'auteur
ça permet de travailler sur le sur le
style et outre les exercices on va
travailler des plantes discours et donc
des plantes discours y en a un que
j'aime il y en a un que j'aime beaucoup
qui est un discours que j'appelle le
discours d'intellectuels et donc qu'est
ce que c'est c'est un discours qui part
du principe que le monde évolue plus
vite que les mots qu'on a pour le
décrire et donc ça veut dire que très
souvent on il ya des phénomènes
émergents autour de nous dans notre
domaine et on n'est pas encore capable
de les décrire et donc ce discours part
de ce travail qui consiste à scruter bas
je pas votre travail votre la société
qui est autour de vous à la recherche de
phénomènes émergents et une fois que
vous en avez identifié un
vous créer un concept qui permet de
rendre compte de ce phénomène et ensuite
vous porter un jugement sur ce concept
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui va
dans le sens de ce que je considère
comme ce qui est bon ou est-ce que ça va
comme mauvais un bon exemple de ça c'est
infobésité en à celui qui a créé le
concept infobésité a rendu un grand
service à tout le monde parce qu'on a
une évolution technologique
l'information en continu qui fait que
les informations au lieu de nous nourrir
intellectuellement nous bourre le crâne
et une fois qu'on a ce concept est bien
ça permet de prendre du recul par
rapport à ce phénomène et de se demander
d'accord qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
j'aimerais quand même juste revenir très
rapidement sur quelque chose que tu as
dit qui m'a tout de suite fait penser à
un philosophe alors évidemment des
formations professionnelles on va peut
parler de philosophie ce que tu dis sur
le langage me fait penser à eagle à deux
titres d'ailleurs première chose c'est
que tu as dit le monde évolue plus vite
que les mots qu'on utilise pour le
décrire et ça ça me fait penser à une
phrase de hegel qui dit que c'est
toujours au au crépuscule que la
chouette de minerve prend son envol il
voulait dire par là que la philosophie
arrive toujours après la réalité arrive
toujours après ce qui a lieu et il ya
une deuxième raison pour laquelle ça me
fait penser à eagle c'est que hegel
disait que le vrai c'est le tout et j'ai
l'impression et là tu vas me dire si
c'est une
une interprétation abusive de ma part
que ce que tu prônes c'est le fait que
tout le monde prenne la parole que tout
le monde s'exprime et que le vrai en en
auto émergera c'est à dire qu'une fois
que tout le monde se sera exprimée est
les choses vont se décanter
naturellement et que c'est comme ça que
finalement la la civilisation avance une
certaine mal apposition d'abord maths ça
en fait à habermas une grande partie de
son oeuvre ça a été de civiliser le
débat public et donc il a il a envisagé
un modèle de conversation où on essayait
d'exclure
d'exclure tout ce qui est intimidations
personnel d'exclure tout ce qu'ils
appellent à l'autorité etc mais il l'a
fait en philosophe il ya un courant de
l'argumentation qui s'appelle la
pragmatique électrique qui est qui a été
lancée par deux chercheurs hollandais
qui s'appelle frank banham et ron et rob
rottendorf donc ils ont créé un courant
qui s'appelle à pragma dialectique et
donc qui est une évolution de la de la
dialectique antique qui essaient de nous
donner des outils concrets qui
permettent de d'avoir des échanges ou en
écartant progressivement tout ce qui
nuit
à la discussion critique on arrive à
faire émerger quelque chose comme une
comme une vérité c'est pas tellement ma
position
je j'aurais tendance à aborder la vérité
plus comme un comme un idéal comme un
idéal individuel donc je me méfie de
l'idée qu'une procédure puisse permettre
de faire émerger la vérité je pense que
la vérité c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on
doit chercher quand on est dans la phase
de création d'un discours c'est l'effort
enfin c'est vraiment difficile l'effort
de se dire est ce que je pourrais pas
détruire cette partie de mon discours en
allant chercher des faits qui le défait
qui vont à son encontre pour pouvoir le
reconstruire plus fort donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on doit poursuivre en
tant qu'individus et un idéal éthique et
je me méfie de ceux qui ont trouvé une
méthode qui permettrait de la faire
émerger intéressant ça rejoint quand
même la notion de dialectique qu'on
utilise
par rapport à socrate c'est à dire la
confrontation qui permet de raffermir
nos idées et nos arguments
d'ailleurs petite question amusante à ce
sujet qu'est ce que ça donne de
rhétoriciens ou même deux traiteurs qui
s'affrontent bah c'est pas très
intéressant toute façon en fait c'est
vraiment une chose que j'essaie de que
j'essaie de faire avancer
il faut arrêter de croire que la guerre
des idées se se remporte avec des
petites phrases et des petites saillies
c'est pas ça la guerre des idées on
prend un exemple que je trouve assez
intéressant
les gens qui débattent par exemple avec
je sais pas moi les gens qui débattent
avec besancenot les gens qui débattent
avec des avec des communistes
ne peuvent pratiquement rien faire par
rapport à leurs adversaires alors que
quelqu'un comme raymond aron qui a pris
le temps de s'installer dans un livre
qui s'appelle l'opium des intellectuels
de démonter un à un tous les postulats
sur lesquels repose la vision marxiste
du monde et bah là on a quelque chose
qui est beaucoup plus résistant à
l'épreuve du temps donc je sais qu'on a
tendance à associer ma discipline au
fait de faire des petites phrases qui
font mouche dans les débats mais ça ne
sert à rien si vous voulez si vous
voulez avancer dans le si vous voulez
gagner la guerre des idées
il faut la tactique est moins importante
que la stratégie et la stratégie ça
suppose d'identifier dans la pensée de
vos adversaires les idées qu'ils
considèrent comme les plus solides et de
faire un travail de fond pour pouvoir
pouvoir les réfuter est donc un livre
comme celui qui a écrit raymond aron on
pourrait prendre d'autres auteurs c'est
un livre qui a un impact beaucoup plus
profond que les gens qui ont essayé de
confronter les gens qui portaient cette
idéologie dans les débats
et est ce que tu penses
que dans certains cas la rhétorique ne
sert plus à rien
je vais illustrer sa
parfois on est confronté à des personnes
qui veulent absolument débattre d'un
sujet sur lesquels on a un désaccord est
très souvent pendant que la personne mme
exposé son point de vue je m'en rends
compte à quel point il me faudrait du
temps pour tout reprendre à la base en
gros pour lui expliquer les trente cinq
années qui ont fait que je pense comme
je pense parce que très souvent j'ai
l'impression qu'on confond ce que l'on
pense et comment on pense et parfois ce
que l'on pense découle de comment on
pense mais on veut pas expliquer à
quelqu'un en quelques lignes comment on
pense on peut pas lui faire pour parler
comme spinoza l'historique des causes et
des effets qui nous ont conduit à penser
comme on pense on s'aperçoit qu'il
faudrait presque partir du postulat
initial et un postulat par définition
c'est difficile à démontrer c'est
difficile a approuvé par des arguments
donc ma question pour la résumer c'est
penses tu que il y a une limite de la
rhétorique dans le débat contradictoire
non mais ça ne sert absolument à rien en
fait en fait qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que le débat contradictoire concrètes
contrairement à ce qu'on pense c'est pas
une situation où ces logos qui est au
coeur du truc ray ce qui est au coeur du
truc c'est les tos ce qu'ils jouent dans
un débat c'est de toute façon les gens
vont pas les gens vont pas vérifié
l'ensemble des choses qui ont été
abordés ce que les gens vous regardent
et c'est ouais il était plus à l'aise ou
alors way s'est énervé ah ouais ce
moment là il a bien bouché et c'est donc
le débat c'est uniquement un exercice
que vous pouvez utiliser pour vous faire
mousser c'est quelque chose qui vous
permet d'apparaître comme comme
quelqu'un voilà qui se laisse pas
démonter dans les débats quelqu'un qui
est capable de démonter les autres mais
ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on fait avancer
les idées parce que si vous voulez
savoir
ce qu'il ya dans la tête de quelqu'un
soit vous devez lire ce qu'il écrit
soit vous devez créer une conversation
mais un débat c'est pas quelque chose
qui permet de mettre les gens dans une
situation propre à ce qui tire le
meilleur de leur intelligence et donc
quand j'ai envie de faire un exercice de
discussion critique c'est quelque chose
que je fais avec mes clients c'est
quelque chose que je fais également avec
des avec des élèves c'est quelque chose
que je peux faire en entreprise c'est
que j'organise une discussion en trois
temps
avec un rôle bien défini il ya un
proposant et il ya un discutant
on commence la discussion ou le
proposant présente c'est la thèse qu'il
a envie de défendre est dans la première
phase l'autre ne pose que des questions
de clarification tiens qu'est-ce que ce
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça et c'est une fois
qu'on est bien clair sur ce dont on
parle on passe à la phase de
confrontation est dans la phase de
confrontation le discutant ne pose que
des questions de vérité et des questions
de validité
donc question de vérité est ce que tu es
sûr de cette proposition question de
validité même si cette proposition est
vrai est ce que tu es sûr que tu as
conclusions découlent nécessairement et
puis troisième phases phase de synthèse
où les gens doivent être capables de
déterminer s'il ya encore des recherches
supplémentaires pour pour savoir s'il ya
un accord est-ce qu'ils ont été capables
de
d'identifier des désaccords profonds où
on est tombés au niveau des valeurs et
donc ou là de toute façon il y aura
incompatibilités et sk des domaines sur
lesquels ils ont trouvé un accord si
notre objectif c'est les c de purifier
la pensée et c'est 2 de tester les idées
c'est vers ce genre de modèle qu'il faut
aller parce que le débat à une autre
fonction c'est très utile d'être bon en
débat parce que c'est bon pour l'image
mais c'est pas bon pour le logos bon là
je peux que te rejoindre puisque c'est
exactement la vision que j'ai sur le le
fameux débat contradictoire
d'autant que les billets qu'on peut
avoir les biais affectif ou
psychologique ce que j'appellerais le
biais de sympathie ou le biais
d'antipathie fait qu'on va pas du tout
avoir la même sensibilité aux arguments
selon qu'ils vont être proférées par
l'un ou par l'autre parfois on va se
montrer extrêmement exigeants dans la
démonstration de quelqu'un avec qui on
n'est pas d'accord et quand quelqu'un
avec qui on sera d'accord va exprimer
une idée une idée très pauvres mais bon
finalement on va là jugée suffisante et
ça c'est quelque chose je pense sur quoi
il faut vraiment mettre en garde
au niveau de notre perception du débat
c'est qu'en réalité
on est la plupart du temps d'accord non
pas avec celui qui a les meilleurs
arguments mais avec celui qui partage
notre avis le débat n'est pas conçu pour
aller vers la vérité le débat est conçu
pour cristalliser solidifier les
positions avant même le débat d'hier
c'est pour ça que moi je l'assimilent à
la logique du spectacle parce que ça
mobilise beaucoup les émotions et qu'on
aime malgré tout la la mise en scène du
conflit quand bien même il serait
purement intellectuelle on est dans une
époque dans laquelle la violence
physique et et est proscrite donc on
trouve des dérivatifs on va trouver le
sport on va trouver le match de football
qui sont une métaphore de la guerre on
va trouver le débat contradictoire qui
va être une autre métaphore de la guerre
est ce que toi il y à des orateurs on va
dire connu du grand public pour lesquels
tu éprouves de l'admiration que tu
trouve particulièrement performant
j'oserais dire qu'ils ont même réussi
parfois à te faire changer ta vision des
choses mais c'est vraiment quand je lis
les gens que je que ça que ça a un
impact pour moi parce que là les
performances dans les débats ça
n'impressionne que la partie
impressionnable de nous donc moi les les
auteurs qui font qu'ils font changé ma
vision des choses c'est ça peut être
soit les grands philosophes sont les
grand essayiste
soit ce qu'ils sont que ceux qui
écrivent de bons livres de nonfiction
c'est ça qui est ça qui est important
pour moi lance moment j'aime beaucoup
rousseau j'aime j'aime beaucoup rousseau
parce que il a su dans son oeuvre
concilier deux stratégies très
différentes pour faire passer ses idées
il à la stratégie classique qui est le
fait de publier des essais
philosophiques qui vont être critiques
et qui vont permettre d'engager un débat
mais il a essayé aussi d'agir sur le
haut niveau de la culture parce que
quand il a écrit la nouvelle héloïse
donc qui est un roman qui a permis pour
la première fois à des personnes des
classes noble de voir ce que c'était que
la subjectivité d'une jeune femme forcée
dans un mariage arrangé eh bien il a
fait beaucoup plus d'impact cette oeuvre
est beaucoup plus d'impact sur les sur
le progrès des droits des femmes que
beaucoup de discours philosophique et
donc j'ai beaucoup aimé ça ça m'inspire
beaucoup ça m'inspire beaucoup mais plus
au niveau des techniques qu'on utilise
c'est à dire que si on veut que notre
oeuvre soit vraiment efficace est
vraiment complète on doit essayer de
viser l'opinion mais on doit aussi
chercher à transformer la culture et là
dessus les formes littéraires et
artistiques sont sont efficaces donc
récemment c'est rousseau qui m'a inspiré
qu'est ce qui te plaît dans la
rhétorique et j'oserais dire qu'est ce
qui t'inspire dans la rhétorique toi à
titre personnel
ce qui me ce qui me plaît c'est que
c'est déjà l'impact que ça
quand on est quand on est capable de
faire régulièrement des des discours il
ya un cercle vertueux qui s'enclenche
donc moi tout est parti du tout est
parti du fait que j'ai commencé à faire
des vidéos sur youtube et donc j'ai
essayé de faire des vidéos sur youtube à
chaque fois en réfléchissant hostiles au
vocabulaire à chaque phrase à la manière
dont mon discours était structuré et
donc avant ça j'ai développé une
compétence qui a fait boule de neige et
qui me permet aujourd'hui de pouvoir
diffuser mes idées auprès d'un auditoire
beaucoup plus large c'est ça qui me
plaît c'est cette idée qu'on a une
discipline qui à la croisée de savoir
qu'ils sont qui sont magnifiques parce
qu'il faut connaître un petit peu
l'anthropologie il faut connaître un
petit peu la psychologie il se nourrir
de littérature il faut se nourrir de
philosophie parce que les philosophes ce
sont quand même des hommes qui ont
poussé très loin le travail sur les
idées et se nourrir de tout ça et en
plus on ajoute cette dimension
artisanale qui consiste à une fois qu'on
a trouvé des idées qui sont bel et bien
formulé agences et tout ça dans un
discours qui va pouvoir avoir un impact
sur le public donc c'est vraiment ça
glem c'est que c'est un c'est un savoir
qui est à la fois
intellectuel mais c'est aussi un savoir
qu'il ya des cas des finalités qui a une
finalité politique alors merci pour la
transition en victor on voit que tu es
un professionnel puisque on va
maintenant pouvoir parler de ton livre
que je leur montre donc douze leçons de
rhétorique pour prendre le pouvoir je ne
te cache pas que quand j'ai vu le titre
dans son entièreté je me suis dit tiens
tiens c'est très explicites comme comme
titre est ce que tu peux nous expliquer
pourquoi le choix de ce titre douze
leçons de rhétorique pour prendre le
pouvoir
alors parce que je il y avait beaucoup
de gens qui venaient me voir en me
disant j'aimerais prendre la parole mais
mais j'ai peur de ce que ça va
déclencher ou alors au manque de respect
au travail
ou alors voilà j'ai pas fait d'études
donc donc j'ai peur de j'ai peur de rien
avoir à dire ou de ne pas savoir bien le
dire le pouvoir dont je parle c'est le
pouvoir que doivent prendre ces gens là
mon livre c'est une incitation à ce que
ces gens puissent reprendre leur part du
pouvoir et ça passe par le fait d'être
capable de bien articuler sa pensée et
de commencer à créer du soutien autour
de cette pensée et c'est pour ça que
j'ai commencé mon livre en montrant le
côté sombre du pouvoir que j'incarne par
staline parce que imaginons qu'on veut
dire que staline a du pouvoir quand on
regarde la vie de cet homme c'est pas
tellement du pouvoir qui l'a on parle
d'un homme qui à la fin de sa journée de
travail il y avait trois limousines qui
partait parce que ils avaient peur d'un
attentat
c'était quelqu'un qui avait un goûteur
qui ne pouvaient qui devait quelqu'un
devait coûter sa nourriture parce qu'ils
avaient peur d'être empoisonné c'est
quelqu'un qui a passé son temps à
craindre 1-1 à craindre une conspiration
contre lui et a créé des conspirations
pour que les pour supprimer ses
adversaires donc c'est quelqu'un qui
avait plein de lever entre les mains
mais des leviers de force et la preuve
qu'il ya une différence entre cette
force et le pouvoir sait que son une
fois que ce l'appareil qu'il a construit
de coercition s'est effondré et bien la
société russe s'est joyeusement lancé
dans la société de consommation et donc
aujourd'hui la société russe c'est une
société qui est aussi capitaliste que
les nôtres avec l'égalité en moins donc
la manière dont il a utilisé le pouvoir
a nui à ses idées et donc moi ce que je
propose de faire dans ce livre c'est
d'acquérir des leviers du pouvoir mais
qui vont être positif pour nos idées
pourquoi parce que encore une fois nos
discours vont puiser dans ce qu'il ya de
meilleur chez ceux qui nous écoutent à
la fin l'objectif c'est qu'on soit porté
par les gens plutôt que d'essayer de
l'époque d'essayer de les réprimer et
par rapport à toujours la notion de
pouvoir
forcément quand on entend le mot pouvoir
on l'a ceci au pouvoir politique et qui
dit pouvoir politique dit aussi partis
politiques pourquoi je parle de ça parce
que quand on est militant politique
généralement on essaie de développer une
certaine rhétorique c'est à dire on
essaie de développer
un disco une argumentation pour
convaincre ou pour persuader un si tu
veux qu'on établisse la distinction on
le fera
pour convaincre ou ou persuader soit
l'adversaire même si l'adversaire
généralement on préfère le combattre que
le convaincre ou celui qui n'est pas
encore qui ne s'est pas encore décidé
est ce que tu penses que cette cette
méthode
qu'on utilise chez les militants
politiques est-ce que c'est efficace la
méthode qui consiste à être très
offensif dans l'argumentation très
combatif et à ne pas être dans la
démarche de rechercher une vérité mais
au contraire de diffuser ce que l'on
estime être la vérité
c'est efficace à court terme c'est c'est
ça le problème c'est ça le problème
qu'ils ont souvent c'est que c'est que
ce qui compte c'est la céda prochaines
échéances électorales et effectivement
mais ça suppose de faire beaucoup de
bruit ça suppose que nos que nos idées
soient diffusés ça suppose de faire le
suppose de faire le buzz et donc pour la
politique telle qu'elle est telle
qu'elle est conçue oui c'est une c'est
une bonne idée de c'est une bonne idée
d'essayer de faire le plus de bruit
possible d'être offensif d'attaquer le
camp adverse oui c'est quelque chose
c'est quelque chose qui peut très bien
qui peut très bien fonctionner donc
seulement parce que ça renforce le
sentiment d'être les gentils face aux
méchants et puis par ailleurs parce que
quand les gens sont exposés aux failles
qui a dans le camp adverse eh ben ils
peuvent ils peuvent être tentés de ils
peuvent être tentés de changer d'avis
oui mais ça ne doit pas remplacer le
travail de fond un travail de fond qui
est qui est vraiment de réfléchir à ce
que serait un monde meilleur travail qui
est fait à part certains en partie les
les universités d'été s'est il parle pas
seulement de tactique dans les
universités d'été il ya un travail de
fond pour essayer de pour essayer de
savoir s'ils sont en accord avec la
vision qu'ils veulent porter j'aurais
pas tellement de conseils à leur donner
mes jeux il ya de plus en plus de
d'université d'été qui me demandent
d'intervenir et je pense qu'un jour je
viendrai parce que c'est ça m'intéresse
de voir comment ça se passe et la
question justement
qui portait sur les partis politiques
que je ne te poser elle mais inspirée
par un épisode que j'ai réalisé sur
simone veil simone veil avec un w la
philosophe qui est extrêmement radical 1
sur le militantisme politique dont elle
dit qu'il a pour vocation de tuer dans
l'âme des hommes le sens de la vérité et
de la justice et c'est vrai que c'est
très difficile lorsque l'on porte des
idées politiques
ben de reconnaître que notre argument
n'est peut-être pas si pertinent ou de
se laisser convaincre par l'argument
d'autrui est ce que tu pense qu'il vaut
mieux faire état
de ses doutes ou est ce que tu pense
qu'il vaut mieux les garder pour soi à
temps de rentrer à la maison pour les
coucher sur le papier pour ensuite
pouvoir les analyser avec recul ça
dépend de la situation quand on est
contenue dans un adverbe quand on est
face à un adversaire sachant que l'on va
être jugé sur notre sur notre image bah
oui là il faut il faut pas il faut pas
montrer d'aveu de faiblesse et là c'est
une bonne idée effectivement d'être
lucide sur nos failles et après de les
travailler au calme pour revenir plus
fort mais là mais la méthode la plus
agréable c'est plus d'avoir une d'avoir
une discussion entre gens qui sont en
désaccord mais qui sont bien
intentionnés et là effectivement on peut
prendre le temps de creuser les
désaccords de les approfondir et
dès que ça devient public c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué non et donc dans l'idéal
c'est un exercice qu'on fait tout seul à
deux et même j'ai envie de dire dos à
dos pour qu'on puisse se focaliser sur
leflux de la pensée à victor de quoi et
ses études nous convaincre un à travers
ta chaîne
de prendre la parole c'est vraiment ça
mon c'est vraiment ça mon objectif c'est
que je
euh si je devais dire le un peu ma
dystopie
mama dystopie c'est un nombre de
commentateurs donc moi quand je fais une
vidéo par exemple je vais prendre un
homme politique et je vais dire regardez
il aurait pu faire comme ça il aurait pu
faire comme ça etc il ya beaucoup de
gens parmi mon public qui sont sur leur
canapé et qui se disent ah ouais
qu'est-ce qu'il est bête cet homme
politique regardez on aurait pu faire
mieux et c'est regarder il a fait un
sophisme regarder s'est trompé mais en
attendant celui qui regarde la vidéo il
a encore sur son canapé alors que
l'homme politique lui il est en train de
se battre dans l'arène et donc c'est ça
dont je ne veux pas et c'est pour ça que
je conçois ma chaîne principale comme un
tandem avec ma chaîne secondaire et
j'essaie aussi souvent que possible
d'amener des gens de ma chaîne
principale vers ma chaîne secondaire
parce que j'ai envie que de plus en plus
de gens se sentent autorisés à se
positionner sur des grandes questions
philosophiques à écrire un essai à
produire un discours j'ai envie de ça
parce que je pense que plus il y aura de
mes concitoyens qui passeront d'une
espèce de contemplation cynique du monde
à une attitude plus active où ils vont
se dire ok j'ai identifié ce problème
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour le
régler eh ben on va être entouré de
beaucoup moins de cynisme et de beaucoup
plus d'optimisme c'est de ça que
j'essaie de convaincre les gens c'est
prenez la parole très bien et heureux en
boucle sur ce que tu disais au début
sur l'utilité de la rhétorique c'est de
passer finalement si je devais employer
un vocabulaire ni de chiens et une
diarra si tu sais tu l'approuvent de
poser de passer d'une position passive à
une position affirmative on est tous les
deux sur youtube donc on sait ce que
c'est que les commentaires sur youtube
et parfois dans les commentaires on sent
un désir de contredire mais de
contredire de manière finalement pas
très efficace parce que un commentaire
va être lu par très peu de personnes il
aura pas vraiment le l'influencent que
nous on pourra avoir à travers une vidéo
et et sans aucune hypocrisie lorsque je
vois un commentaire très critique mais
construit avec du fond j'ai vraiment
envie de dire à son auteur mais fait une
vidéo pour expliquer comment tu pense
qu'il faudrait voir les chose parce que
là ce serait dans une démarche active
l'énergie qui se dégage d'une
vidéo dans laquelle on va proposer
quelque chose n'est pas la même que
celle dans un commentaire animé par le
ressentiment et la preuve c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui passent de
commentateurs à vidéaste et qui change
de ton lorsqu'ils deviennent vidéaste
parce que c'est pas pareil parce que là
je t'adresse à des gens et donc si tu
n'as rien d'autre à leur proposer que de
de la crispation de la colère ou de
l'agacement bon ben c'est sûr que ça va
pas être très apprécié par les
spectateurs donc mais est-ce que l'image
que je viens de prendre la différence
entre le commentateur et de et le
vidéaste peut s'appliquer à ce que tu
décris oui tout à fait tout à fait je
trouve que la vidéo qui va c'est une
vidéo qui va demander beaucoup de temps
mais dont je suis vraiment très fier
c'est le à la fin de l'année dernière
j'ai sollicité ma communauté je leur ai
donné un plan de disco et je leur ai dit
vous filmez vous filmer ce discours face
caméra et donc après j'ai pu faire une
compilation des discours que j'ai trouvé
les meilleurs mais en plus bas sous la
vidéo les gens ont regardé les vidéos
des dessins des oreilles et il y en a
sur cette base qui ont qui ont lancé ce
qu'ils ont lancé leur chaîne youtube et
et là dessus il ya des projets qui n'est
ce pas ce que l'objectif évidemment
c'est pas seulement de rester dans la
bulle internet l'objectif c'est que
après ça débouche sur des choses
concrètes de gens qui lancent des
associations de gens qui lancent des
entreprises de gens qui s'engagent c'est
ça qui est important et donc c'est aussi
pour ça que
j'exploite assez peu le biais de
négativité dans mes vidéos parce que
quand je fais une vidéo sur une
personnalité neuf fois sur dix et c'est
peut-être même plus de neuf fois sur dix
je prends cette personnalité pour
montrer ce qu'elle fait de bien pour
montrer ce qu'on pourrait récupérer et
s'approprier donc c'est je pense
également que les chaînes de clash ce
sont des chaînes qui peuvent fonctionner
ça peut faire un peu d'audience mais
l'impact
civique nuls alors qu'est ce que tu
dirais à celui ou celle qui voudrait ou
qui songerait à créer sa chaîne youtube
mais qu'ils n'oseraient pas le faire a
joué une première vidéo
j'ai fait une j'ai fait une vidéo là
dessus ou g où j'ai montré une de mes
premières vidéos c'est une catastrophe
soyez les bienvenus dans votre leçon de
rhétorique aujourd'hui ouvrez bien vos
yeux vos oreilles et votre coeur
d'enfant nous allons apprendre à
raconter des histoires
la deuxième fonction des histoires nous
intéresse tout particulièrement atone
la première fois qu'on se met dans cet
exercice parce que c'est très bizarre
c'est très bizarre d'être face à une
caméra on parle à quelqu'un mais y'a
personne et il faut faire attention à
vous on met notre regard il faut le
faire avec le bon niveau d'énergie c'est
vraiment un travail d'acteur donc
évidemment que la première fois qu'on
fait des vidéos c'est nul mais la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'il a pas beaucoup de
gens qui les regarde et au à force de
faire des vidéos et bien on devient de
meilleur là dedans c'est comme toute
compétence est quelque chose qui se sait
quelque chose qui se développe et si
vous avez la motivation de le faire ça
va venir c'est l'avenir moi j'ai
commencé avec un avec un micro
complètement pourri j'ai commencé en
haussant en copiant vaguement les codes
de ce que j'avais cru qui fonctionnait
chez les autres alors que c'était déjà
ringard donc non le les premières vidéos
qu'on fait sur youtube c'est nul et puis
celle qu'on fait ensuite c'est un petit
peu mieux c'est un petit peu mieux et
voilà sur tout ce qui est important
c'est de ne pas céder aux critiques qui
essaie de vous intimider de vous dire
ferme ta chaine tu dois pas décliné sur
ce sujet et c'est ces gens ne servent à
rien et tout ce qui le montrent ces leur
petitesse
pour finir victor
une question un petit peu plus
personnelle et je te laisserais vraiment
prendre le temps de développer
qu'est ce qui te fait vibrer
ce qui me fait vibrer
c2c que assez souvent tu sais quand on
compte quand on fait ce qu'on fait il ya
effectivement des moments où on commence
à se mettre en mode automatique donc
c'est à dire qu'on sait qu'on doit
sortir une vidéo et donc on se relance
mais mais on a des processus et donc on
perd un petit peu la flamme est donc
dans ces moments là je me replonge dans
un été que j'ai passés entre ma classe
de première es ma classe de terminale
j'étais en gt en première littéraire et
j'ai passé un été à écrire un essai
politique j'ai passé un été à écrire un
essai politique où je voulais vraiment
changer le monde enfin avec tout une
tout un blâme de ce qu'allait pas dans
la société actuelle etc et je prenais un
plaisir fou à le faire j'avais
l'impression comme ça de tracer un
nouveau sentier de penser et mon rêve
alors c'était de c'était d'être comme
les essayistes que je que je voyais qui
m'inspiraient d'être comme le personnage
d illusions perdues de balzac voilà
quelqu'un qui est qu'ils donnent tout
pour pouvoir pouvoir créer des idées
pour pouvoir les diffuser et je rêvais
de ça évidemment je n'ai rien fait de ce
document parce que après j'ai pris après
j'ai enfin la vie m'a rattrapé j'ai fait
mes études j'ai fait d'autres choses
mais quand aujourd'hui je me dis voilà
est-ce que j'ai vraiment envie de faire
cette vidéo est ce que j'ai vraiment
envie de travailler je me reconnecte à
ce mec qui dans sa chambre écrivait un
manifeste politique et qui n'avait pas
de public pour pour diffuser ses idées
et donc aujourd'hui pour moi toutes les
fois où je peux prendre la parole face à
vous face à un public j'essaie de me
raccrocher à ce privilège ce privilège
que c'est que d'avoir la possibilité de
partager les choses qui nous tiennent à
coeur c'est ça qui me fait vibrer eh
bien ce sera un très beau mot de la fin
merci à toi victoire
merci charles
[Musique]